[Musique]
me mêler de la vie
si tous qu'on est astucieux peine
le plus sérieux à jouer et à gagner
[Musique]
alors oui à temps je jette enlever ça
qu'est ce qui t'as fait ça enfin au bas
alors qu'est ce que c'est et j'ai été
attaqué c'est pas que je suis tombé en
plein milieu d'un vol de foulards et là
il ya un foulard j'en ai la tombe est qu
ils m'ont mis à mal sinon ça va mieux je
livrais je livrais les dessins à l'école
des saints mais oui c'est que vous êtes
quelqu'un qui aime pas la peinture c'est
possible possible ce sont les dessins
d'hervé le grand oui aujourd'hui perdu
tout ce que j'avais à dire non pas quand
je vais à ranger sa mort heureusement
que je connais je remets toi remets toi
sauf à jabbeke se rebellant lever 5 0 ce
fut mon action donc quand je suis
rappelé dans un arbre wilbek saint
cybard oui je sais ça supplique dont
vous avez devant vous trois dessins bon
il s'agit de les mettre dans l'ordre
logique
pour cela il faut bien regarder la scène
et être extrêmement attentif et d'après
certains détails vous devez comprendre
qu'un dessin doit venir avant l'autre et
c'est bon il y en a trois suffit de les
mettre les trois dans l'ordre c'est un
peu comme le tiercé attention regardez
ce premier dessin c'est une scène de
pêche bien évidemment bon avant de dire
quoi que ce soit regardons un autre
dessin rien je ris ah bon ça ne va pas
mieux
finalement tu ris tout seul tu ne sais
même plus pourquoi
bon moi c'est encore la même scène
apparemment ça va vivre dans un manière
d'être la scène d'ailleurs i té le bord
de la scène
oui c'est le cpo ce qui brille
effectivement et voilà un troisième
décès
j'ai l'impression voiture oui que sans
l'avoir fait exprès j'ai passé les
dessins cette fois ci et pour la
première fois dans le bon ordre à quai
sont toujours tu vois je il aura fallu
mais celle qu'est ce que ça peut faire
ah ben oui qu'est ce que ça peut faire
le problème cette se rendent compte qu
une suite logique
regarde tient à temps je me suis pas
trompé non ça m'a l'air d'être ça il
pêche
bon là il a trois poissons fin avant
beaucoup
bon là il a un peu plus de poissons ils
marchent toujours sa mort oui et puis
enfin il a beaucoup de poissons oui
voilà c'est tout simplement ça c'est ça
tu vois la ccba alors ça c'était tout
simple tu n'as pas réussi à me coller
encore une fois on va te coller sur le
point commun tu crois que tu as me
croyez moi c'est de la confiance
on va voir j'ai la sorte d'arriver sans
encombres jusque là bah oui bah ça on ne
mord clou par le bec
si vous avez lu ce qu'il est arrivé là
mais on était inquiet ne perdons pas de
temps à pleaux fabrice qui a poussé
moussu fais le toi et ça fabrice oui
fabrice tu viens oui je viens
voilà je viens parce qu'à toi fabrice a
bien attendu cette fois ci j'ai envie de
faire une petite sieste moi j'ai pas nos
côtés est-ce que nous avons une fois
comme un moment entre vous trois
roumains même toujours oui alors je vais
te dire ce que je suis moi aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que tu es un légume un légume
qu'on trouve surtout en bretagne
c'est là que je suis le plus célèbre
d'ailleurs oui et en général on me mange
froid
ou alors avec une petite sauce ravigote
tu vois ce que je veux dire je suis un
artichaut et je suis très amusant à
manger on met feuilles comme une
marguerite duras je t'aime un peu
beaucoup mais alors non seulement je
suis très bon du goût un peu de très
bons mais en plus tout le monde dit que
je suis très bon pour la santé
quand on me mange il faut simplement
faire attention parce que à l'intérieur
j'ai plein de poils vous les a enlevées
par c'est très désagréable
le poil de tahar ben jelloun tête
d'artichaut d'ailleurs ça y est je vais
gargariser malgré l'embellie ce mot
parler alors bon alors fabrice moi je
fais partie de la mer et je suis aussi
vaste que la mère s'est forcé puisque là
où l on me trouve aussi dans les mers
très profonde au plein milieu du
pacifique vous aurez bien du mal à me
voir car il fait très sombre
les supports des coutumes laisse
contempler très volontiers je réserve
même de très joli spectacle avec mes
coquillages mais presse sommet rocher
weesa algues et aussi hélas mais épave
de bateau naufragé que les amateurs de
plongée sous-marine apprécie beaucoup
qu'est-ce que ça je sais pas ce que
c'est réfléchissez un petit buzz que
pour l'instant je ne sais pas pour ce
monsieur est venu mais je vais je vais
essayer un oui alors moi moi je suis un
vêtements que portent sur tous les
petits garçons oui je me souviens quand
j'allais à l'école j'en avais une ne tue
pas ce que je veux dire ne va pas je
suis une culotte un une culotte que j'ai
bien usée sur les bancs de l'école
d'ailleurs croire que je peux être aussi
un pantalon nous commandons les grands
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi on parle
beaucoup plus souvent de moi à propos
d'une culotte que d'un pantalon
je dirais même qu'on parle de moi
surtout quand je suis une culotte usées
et raccommoder tu vois ce que je veux
dire oui tu as trouvé
oui à j'ai trouvé parce que c'est toi
qui m'a mis sur la voie moi je t'ai bien
non je te remercie parce qu'au départ
tout concorde avec son histoire
d'artichaut je cherchais mon situe
facilement bas c'était facile mais
c'était plus difficile
moi c'était plus difficile la jeune âge
est complètement si je puis dire s'il
connaît et puis alors à la fin grâce à
pouss moussu je pouvais je pense que
vous avez également trouver vous savez
maintenant qu'il s'agit d'un fonds voilà
ce qu'ils ont en commun le fonds
d'artichauts et le fond le fond de la
mère en fille dans les sommaires et et
nous avions de force 2 sur le fond de
culotte voilà très exactement
eh ben j'ai encore trouvé c'est moi le
plus fort bravo fabrice of bon alors tu
vas attendre qu'ils tableau oui bon
alors cette semaine c'est difficile non
aussi c'est un modifie son nom j'ai bien
travaillé je crois enfin j'espère oui
mais c'est un mot difficile on en voit
ce que moi je suis extrêmement bon alors
je vais bien je vais t
alors c'est un mot en neuf lettres roll
hall of thrones c'est un mot en neuf les
gens commencent par quoi ça commence par
un n
voilà l aisne alors cette petite reine
voilà et la dernière c1 e 1
voilà alors tu ne poses des questions et
je vais t'aider
le mieux possible un animal non c'est
pas un animal un arbre c'est pas un
arbre une plante
ah oui oui tu as trouvé c'est une plante
tu vois tu vas tu y arrives tu vois
c'est une plante une fleur ah non c'est
pas une fleur fassi c'est une fleur si
c'est une plante est une fleur c'est le
trou alors c'est au nom et notre oubli
mais est ce que c'est une plante est une
fleur enfin bravo ambages temps merci tu
devais m'aider ça m'aide c'est une belle
fleur c'est une belle fleur dire une
mauvaise foi c'est une fleur moyenne
mais très belle à travers elle que tu te
donnes une lettre pour t'aider encore un
petit peu
bah oui parce que je vais le donner je
vais donner la 4e là
voici ses seins nus une wii quatrième
lettre
oui 1 2 3 4 c'est une plante très
spécial ah oui c'est pas une orchidée
donc pas ce qu a fait des fautes
d'orthographe
oui mais avec we are back en même temps
on l'a fait pire 1 rue alors oui oui oui
alors qu'est-ce que ça peut bien elle
est très belle
c'est une plante que l'on trouve dans
nos régions oui oui oui est ce qu est ce
que c'est une plante qu'on trouve près
de l'eau am est hâtive attitude brûle
dubrulle je brûle et oui elle est même
tout près elles mêmes de dessus hein
t'as trouvé ça y est c'est pas possible
comme dans c'est pas possible si on loue
un élu fars voilà un élu fasse un ennemi
femme nue ça avec un e à la fin
oui un homme comme un phare de voiture
exact c'est simplement exactement alors
et bien nénuphars ont bien écrire
tranquillement comme ça hein ça n'est ni
ça va encore le phare c'est pas un phare
d'automobiles c'est une p -h
arm ont eu faire passer coûte que c'est
vraiment très compliqué laurent gras
très compliqué mais dis-moi fabrice pour
le nénuphar il ya autre chose qui est
compliqué c'est d'arriver à recueillir
ces graines
parce que si tu fais pas attention mais
elle tombe au fond de l'eau et tous les
pères alors pour les récolter
il faut envelopper les fruits dans un
petit sac de mousseline juste avant
qu'ils soient mûres quoi de cette façon
tu pourras sommet d'autres nénuphars ou
si tu préfères d'autres lunes d'eau
puisque on les appelle comme ça soit je
trouve cela très jolie une lune dos une
lune d'eau et bozouls et d'eau
jordan lui dont marc dolez gens dedans
je voudrais bien qu'on aille voir belle
bella j'ai hâte de voir belbel quoi une
lutte dos elle a une fleur qui pourrait
nous servir d'emblème pour notre jeu
musical tu veux mais cris m'aider à
écrire une lettre où il y a quelqu'un
qu'il faut absolument que je re mère
parce qu'il m'a fait un très joli cap à
l'est alors je rappelle que c'est avec
les notes de la gamme que je dois
compléter les mots que tu vas me dire ça
donc il faut que j'ai remarqué qu'il va
feindre et jolies captures mère culture
mr cdh et le mr énormément si c'est oui
je le remercie calme afin très joli cas
à un serrage licata temps je suis à toi
un très joli cas dont celles à venir si
vaste qu'il n'a fait un très joli cadeau
un cadeau que je t'apporte rennes séjour
pour que tu puisses l'add on joue plus
je voudrais que tu puisses laddh
mon cadeau à la de l'ade laddh le attend
alors la ddt mais admis la mire et c'est
ça voilà aujourd'hui je ne vais pas pris
avec moi parce que j'ai j'avais beaucoup
de courses à faire et j'aurais pu
l'oublier dans un tac alors vraiment
c'est mort est alors seul vélo me dit
voilà l état dans l'état
alors vraiment pas taxées alors donc il
faut absolument que j'écrive une très
jolie lettre de remerciement à ses
admirateurs tu sais comme moi les petits
cadeaux et même les gros entretiennent
c'est facile la mi juillet les petits
cadeaux entretiennent l'amitié très bien
dit on vu
laisse moi de parler un peu de ce cadeau
j'en rêvais depuis longtemps
c'est un diamant et quelle gamme en pas
une petite poussière de diamant qu'il
faudrait regarder avec un stop un grosse
cote 1 mu un mac os comme le mien c'est
un diamant gros comme et comme je sais
pas mais en fait il y très très gros il
doit peser
je ne sais pas mais enfin ce que je sais
c'est qu'on appelle ça iter le
magnifique vais iter un solitaire ça va
pas caen 1 1 réalité en non plus un
militaire ni non pendant que non je
préfère un solitaire un solitaire mois
en solitaire tu sais dans le fond c'est
merveilleux ça coûte très cher mais ce
qui compte dans un sac à dos et le geste
malgré tout je pense que bijoux de cette
nature doit bien coûter de culture trop
fort 7000 francs
au moins ça ne serait pas de satan lui a
pas de recommencer l'avenir oui c'est un
bijou qui doit coûter au moins être à la
halle à 7000 francs et trois choses à
trouver trois choses à trouver one est
quoi récit si les adore un doré un
kwassa manif a dit hun sen sol un
wimille eu la gentillesse si c'est bon
c'est bon si je me fais bien ce site we
say say me oui c'est à 106 me dit ça y
est s'ils me sens aimé la silla un bijou
qui va sauter de 6000 à 7000 font en
fait celui là il était difficile et si
je l'ait fait exprès et robben et non il
veut qu'on chante maintenant pour moi
parce que je suis épuisé carrément allez
on chantait dit elle n'en peut plus
les quatre tapis
déjà papa d'amy le katla lit ou des
rocky secret que la vie majed désiste
léger choc fait des choses mais comme
juni pas de mine war livre on a fait
attention les gars ça qu'ils sont partis
sans répit les caps a mis son de retard
il aime la vie
oui
alors
aujourd'hui vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]
la fatigue